okay so does that mean that that dude is
going to be there from now
so I don't really know what skippity
toilet is and
see I don't know what skippity toilet is
and I
I didn't know what Sonic was either but
I still played Sonic.exe so I figured
this will be fun and I can get some
insight into the true workings of
whatever the skivity and or toilet is
I really don't know
hi
hello
I don't know if this is going to give me
a good idea of what skibety toilet is
but this is kind of a research Adventure
where we're kind of we're going into
this blind together I'm assuming none of
you know because I've said multiple
times now I don't know what Skitty
toilet is and everyone just says oh
don't
don't bother
and I'm like okay
oh it doesn't tell me why
anyway
prison door
need a long pick
um why am I in prison
can anyone get a lock pick
lock pick
oh
nice
well all right
um
so why uh was I put in prison what kind
of skippity crimes did I commit
can I get a skivity lawyer
um
is that going to give me the AR Vision
nope okay all right then
guess they weren't skilled enough to
program that I guess it was a little too
complex for this game developer to
implement an AR mask
oh well whatever
skippity High
skip the left security right skippity
left
security light
give me the door
skippity nothing oh let's give it a lean
give me the no clip
all right fine oh skippity run
oh
hello
skippity toilet skippity bathroom no
skippity desk
why do I have macular degeneration my my
eyesight doesn't go very far
oh
well that's nice I didn't know I needed
Hive skippity bones
what are you what are you doing here
why am I still moving
why were you still moving
was I moving
give me the hallway
High skippity science
elements I don't recognize this chart
oh okay
skippity Pewters
give me the Sprint yup give me the dead
end
all right this has got to go somewhere
maybe the one on the left
security nothing
is this gonna go somewhere or what I
want something
hello
oh
skippity Aperture Science
skibity portal
security high security
ation
whole
all right
well this doesn't seem too bad
not sure what's going on here but it's
fine
hello this isn't a server room what are
you talking about
oh yeah
oopsie
um
I don't know if that was the best thing
that I could have done
for experiments oh
maybe I should have looked into what
they were doing here before I just
restarted the entire system it's a
Stargate
all right
oh portal
[Music]
okay I'm gonna Scooby-Doo surprises
around every corner
checking checking what
oh
I love that game
all right
well this has been fun
I don't know why I've done any of it but
it was really fun
skippity High
need to keep but I just had a key
wait did I see something at the end of
the hallway there
hello
there wasn't a key on one of these
things was there
is there a key in there
I don't think there was anywhere else to
go and it's not like
yeah I must have missed it
oh my god well
so the truth is I did see something down
there hi I have to know
I still don't know what skippity toilet
is all right
skippity speed
[Music]
let's give the key
okay so does that mean that that dude is
going to be there from now
on
what's wrong with you don't do that to
me
holy crap
so where'd you come from
why can't I see you
I don't like this
I'm skippity scared
I'm running oh crap
oh boy yeah ring around this Rosy
huh what's up
oh
interesting so I think I need to get
down to the end of the hallway because
I'm pretty sure that's where you
skippity came from
I just need it
patience
that's terrifying what
what
the hey
I need to go that way you're not in here
are you
no
[Music]
can you go by the door there and you
just run on past
and I'm gonna go buy and I'm gonna get
whatever you're hiding
what are you doing
Oh I thought that
I'm going for it
oh wait there was an offshoot now
[Applause]
I
wanna know what it was before it got
remastered that's what I'd like to know
anyway I don't skip it a give up
I'm not gonna skip it a surrender
so there was like some I don't know room
like a whole opening that opened up to
the right over there I don't know what
that's about but
that's why it's one supposed to be to do
and that's what I'm gonna do
damn
well skippity go I just had to say
something okay he's gonna pop up right
there immediately right whoa
oh oh oh oh oh oh you you yeah come on
yeah come on
that guy skippity slides so why is the
enemy that's killing me not a toilet I
thought that that was gonna be like the
thought that was a whole thing here is
this skippity toilet is this an accurate
representation of the skippity gameplay
that you all love and enjoy and that
kids are apparently stealing their
parents credit cards for
I don't know what this is
yippee take my money
hey
oh wait what am I an idiot yes no don't
answer that oh God okay
so you're gonna You're Gonna Go On by
yeah
that's what I thought look I'm just
gonna follow him because apparently he
sticks down here a little bit oh wow oh
wow that's a long way to go oh God oh my
God I'm good I'm doomed I'm doomed where
am I going I don't know I'm coward I'm
coward on cowarding I'm cowarding what
I'm gonna do oh perfect
he's definitely not going to turn this
way
why would he do that
why would he do that that son of I
have to know what the mystery of the
skibety toilet is I have to know all
right
doing sideways
get away skippity Escape
follow him down why don't
don't what are you doing what are you
doing don't don't don't
okay skippity shut up why Scott
Skitty whoa skippity no
where am I going skippity where
skippity who where am I skippity what
I don't skippity stand
understand
I don't know where I'm going I don't
know why I'm going I think I'm reaching
the truth of it all of everything
all over the world
what what what what what what what
do you mean what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean
that one doesn't even say it needs a key
I can't see anything
how am I supposed to do anything if I
can't see where I is
am I just going backwards I don't even
know where I I don't know where I ended
up
I think I got around TV Sam over there
but I don't know
Maybe
maybe this is where I came from I don't
know when did I get to the brick floor
where'd you come from what are you
how am I supposed to find anything
hey you got key
oh
key all right okay well that's something
sorry a skippity ski
what
boy do
okay
oh wow
oh but that's bad not what I want
but that but that's not what I want
okay there was so much stuff that I
abandoned in my Sprint
to safety so there must be more stuff
over this in way
okay anybody see a key
oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh
shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh how is that
fair
you can just go through the goddamn
table is that what you're telling me you
can go through the goddamn table why am
I still trying this I don't understand
why I'm still trying this it's not
making any sense why would I why would I
keep trying this why why would I keep
trying this why why would I keep going
on this why would I why would I do this
more why would I do this more why would
I more this
well when you're the skippity best
better than the skippity rest
Can't Stop
just because you're at the top doesn't
mean you can't keep climbing
keep reaching higher
okay he's gonna come in here he's gonna
come to the door
or if you can see me if I turn my light
off
okay there he goes there's skippity
scoes so he's skippity scoing over there
give me scooting
really
wait a minute oh that's a problem
oh that's a problem
oh I should have gone the other way
because he can run me ah okay well
I'm doomed
aye
oh no not doomed
okay so if I have enough Runway I can
get around him no probe
it's short for problem
okay there must have been a key in here
somewhere I bet I bet
but uh you got to be careful he can just
kind of go through the tables
don't know if you knew that can I
he was right here wow that's so
convenient
but if all this key does
is open this door
then how is that helpful there's nothing
I need to go back for right
nothing would have changed
it's all still whoa There It Is God damn
it
I have the key you can't
oh God damn
I swear to God I swear I swear I swear
this is gonna be so worth it when I get
to the skippity end of The skippity Saga
you're all gonna thank me you're all
gonna thank me and then you're gonna
like and then you're gonna subscribe
that's what's gonna happen you're gonna
like subscribe and then you're gonna
write in the comment thank you Mark
thank you for sacrifice give me
sacrificing brother
twizard not a key here before there's
not a key there
so you have to come back around and do
the whole thing for some reason
that's just the way it be
this is the way it be
he really wants to be right there and
he's gone okay
oh why that's weird that's different
does he always do that
oh
oh frick
over oh yeah try me try me try try where
are you going where'd you go
where'd you go
oh
which way
which way you go
ah frick
oh
oh perfect perfect I can go around him
in this big open cafeteria oh frick go
Frick oh frick oh frick oh frick I'm the
best I'm
this game I'm sort of skibity.exe I'm so
good God damn I'm good
I'm playing a level they never could
have imagined and now he's going to be
all the way over here God damn I'm good
[Music]
my skibety skill
unmatched unwavering huge
huge in its girth
grab this
grab grab okay
Scooby go for it
skippity going for it oh my God what
what do you what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean what do you mean
oh
it's getting disclosed yes oh
hi
um
it's not what I was skipped expecting
oh
anybody seen a toilet
you guys got any toilets
uh huh
oh great just go here
oh boy
that sucks for you wait what's happening
yeah that sucks for you
yeah that sucks
yeah that sucks right there
haha
okay if you give me a key to go back
then I'm it probably wants me to go back
for another key I bet if there's another
key over here then I definitely have to
go back probably
oh
I'll need to get the
what what do you what do you mean what
do you mean I'll need to get the
documents what what do you mean
what do you mean
I don't know where the documents are
um
but I guess I'll go around
please tell me he's not just gonna turn
around and come after me immediately
oh he's dumb don't worry guys he's dumb
damn it
okay what documents I don't know
you better not turn around I swear to
God
yeah I don't know what documents you're
talking about
uh
uh-huh Bingo documents give me the
documents
what do you mean by you better not just
if you do I'm I'm All That foreign
videos over instantly
okay
they in here again
I'm searching skibity high and skibety
low and and me playing through this game
probably is a new skibety low for me but
I feel like there's no documents here
um
hey Lee I don't know what I mean by
documents
I got nothing okay
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean what do you mean
documents
oh why why would you do this to me why
would you do this why would you suddenly
do that
you chasing me
why would he suddenly be free that
doesn't make any sense was it getting
close to the documents I don't know
where documents are I don't have any
documents
just let me Scooby-Doo win
I want to be skippity done
I don't know what your documents are
what do you mean
guys there's no skippity documents
there's no skippity scocuments
I've got no documents
there ain't no documents there's no
there's no documents
I ain't got no scocuments
I don't know what you mean the documents
get the documents the documents what do
you mean the documents what documents
are you referring to I don't know any I
don't know any
documents
I don't know about no documents
that dot oh
you're gone
but I still don't got no documents I
don't know what you mean by
documents
what what mean you what do you mean
I came through all this I came so far
I came for documents
I played all the way through skippity
EXE
and I still don't know what skippity
toilet means
I don't know what any of it means
oh Wham
dummy
oh
domey
okay so I don't know where us documents
are
um
but they're not here uh they're not
there they're not Over Yonder they're
not on the benches they're not anywhere
oh wet
do you know where the documents are
well I'm dead
oh great skip we all
and all right great stuff everybody if
you want to know the secret of skippity
toilet I'll tell you I actually learned
it in the entirety of this experience
and the truth is